und es ist eine geschichte mit happy end
und 100 hundewelpen konnten beamte des
zolls retten
als sie einen elegant ihr transport aus
osteuropa stoppen denn lieferwagen war
bis unters dach voll mit gitterboxen
darin drei katzenbabys und 94 schwache
todkranke hundewelpen diese einige von
ihnen konnten jetzt aber hier in einem
ulmer tier in einem ulmer tierklinik
unter graf in ein tierheim 26 von ihnen
genau da wollen wir jetzt einmal
hinschauen denn mein kollege sascha
baumann ist vor ort wir wollen natürlich
wissen wie es den tierbabys geht aber
jetzt sehe ich gerade mir zugeschaltet
ist nämlich der tierheimleiter reift man
dass man die hunde 26 von ihnen sind bei
ihnen untergekommen wie haben sie die
ganze überstanden
ja also bei uns sonntagvormittag der
anruf ein vom zoll transporte gestopft
mit tieren da war noch nicht klar wie
viele tiere mir sondern direkt vor ort
gefahren haben den transporter gesehen
haben aufgemacht und dann schauten uns
quasi dann 200 welpen äuglein an
dramatische situation auch einfach das
war dann so wir wollten eigentlich die
ganzen 197 tiere beschlagnahmen das war
mit dem trainer amt auch so abgesprochen
wir waren da einer meinung es wurde
nochmal rücksprache mit der
staatsanwaltschaft gehalten die hat
wiederum wenn der richter rücksprache
gehalten und der hat dann gesagt nein
das können wir nicht machen ihr nehmt
nur die beschlagnahme nur die tiere die
offensichtlich krank und zu jung sind
also uns völlig unverständlich
es waren de facto gefälschte papiere
also impfpässe mitunter eu pässe das
hätten völlig ausgereicht um den
transport erstmal stillzulegen um dann
zu sagen so jetzt kontrollieren wir
jetzt prüfen wie tollwut täter wie es
überhaupt aussieht also mir nicht
verständlich wirklich warum der
transportern mit 70 tieren weiterfahren
durfte die 70 tiere durften wohin genau
dann weiterfahren was passiert jetzt mit
ihnen
ja das ist eine gute frage also zielort
war angegeben spanien
ich glaube das nicht ich glaube die
werden unterwegs schon vor shepherd
vielleicht sind auch welche schon
verkauft das wissen wir nicht
also für uns eine ganz dramatische
situation wir wissen nämlich nicht was
passiert mit den tieren selbst ein
klarer vorwurf auf jeden fall an die
behörden in diesem fall aber die tiere
die jetzt bei ihnen sind sie haben
gerade gesagt sie habe die besonders
jungen und kranken bekommen wie geht es
diesen tieren jetzt und vor allem was
genau passiert jetzt mit ihm gibt es da
strenge vorgaben was man tun muss wenn
man solche illegalen hunde transports
weil sich dann auf nimmt ja also wir
haben die bei uns in quarantäne
da stehe ich auch gerade links von mir
sind die ersten hunde welpen auch drin
und tiere
die müssen jetzt unter quarantäne
gestellt werden dh die nächsten wochen
passiert meditieren gar nichts außer
dass wir die erst mal gesund pflegen
die haben teilweise starken durchfall
auch flohbefall also ektoparasiten die
haben würmer das müssen wir alles
behandeln
mit unseren tierärzte und dann werden
wir mit der behörde dann werden wir drin
abend auch gucken wie es weiter geht
also wir versuchen die natürlich so
schnell wie möglich und rechtlich
möglich dann in neues zuhause zu
vermitteln wenn sie da ungefähr sagen
wie lange es dauert bis die ersten
liebevollen familien diese tiere dann
aufnehmen können sich bei ihm melden
können ja also ich würde mal behaupten
so sechs wochen wäre jetzt mal so die
erste frist die wir überbrücken müssen
und dann können so die ersten sich
melden
dann wissen wir genau was wie es genau
aussieht